[Music]
so we're in a car market and you can see
there's a lot of these bleaching
products being displayed if you look at
Kara while she is actually super super
white in parts of West Africa skin
bleaching is big business and it's big
across Asia the Caribbean the Middle
East and other parts of Africa - by 2018
the global skin lightening industry will
be worth almost twenty billion dollars
but here in Ghana there's a new
generation that's pushing back there
spreading awareness about the dangers of
skin whitening and they're fighting back
against the social pressure to bleach my
name is comfor Alfre i used to skin
bleach but now i campaign against it i
am a filmmaker and an animator when I
was growing up I hated my skin
complexion I hated being dark
that's why I did black Barbie because I
believe as a filmmaker you have a
responsibility in terms of what you show
when I was 23 I stood in front of my
local cosmetic counter this was the
first time I had my first bleaching
cream encounter will this work I ask the
Asian assistant of course it will rid
your skin of his black existence people
go and look at my two sisters and say oh
they're so beautiful and then that made
me feel that maybe being dark isn't
actually beautiful going out you see
young guys like in life girls choosing
like a girls over you and then you feel
that no you are the problem
Society constantly bombarding us with
images of life girls versus darker girls
when I first got that product and I
opened it I was like yes I'm going to
get light yes I'm going to be like my
sister and my mom Ghana made headlines
in 2016 when it banned skin bleaching
products with hydroquinone which is a
potentially dangerous chemical
hydroquinone was supposed to be off the
shelves by the end of 2016 but more than
three months later we still found it for
sale at the market we reached out to
Ghana's Food and Drugs authority to find
out why these products are still for
sale but we haven't heard back so this
is the product I use for skin light is
this white one with the orange when I
was young when I was 23
[Music]
well here in Africa that's a saying that
goes that when you're going to church
and you see a white man on the way you
better go back home because you've seen
good chica
open camara directs the FC skin and
beauty clinic in Accra she focuses on
skin repair and she's also a molecular
biologist in Ghana it's a popular saying
so in church day if you see a white
person you think oh that is the life -
how much people want to be fair that's
how much people give lighter skin people
or Caucasians that respect so people
also want to be as close to white as
possible and bleaching is the short
tickets to be in white
chicas clients often don't even know
what they've been putting on their skin
that's because a lot of these products
are mixed at home and then they're sold
through social media or under the
counter part from hydrocodone you'll
find that other people use things like
cement water cements for building people
have also used hair relaxes so you find
that the clients will come and then and
when you join the consultation you'll
find that they're using all sorts of
things - to lighten their skin but it's
actually bleaching
[Music]
so we've been walking around a crowd
just to see some of the products that
are being displayed on billboards and as
we can see over here this is BIOS skin
which actually doesn't have the illegal
chemical hydro cream in it which is
actually good but still it's promoting
this idea of lighting in your skin which
you know to me is a bit of an issue
because as much as it doesn't have this
legal chemical but what is it saying to
a young girl young dark-skinned girl
that oh you must be lighter or you must
use this product so you can look like so
even though it doesn't have it it's
still trying to promote at this ideal
being the lighter is better as you can
see the model there is a light skinned
beautiful model comfort started reaching
because of social pressure but that's
also why she stopped it got to the point
when I was getting lighter and lighter I
was actually happy as I hey I'm getting
light I'm getting like but the moment my
friend pointed it out to me that you
know you're getting like you it that you
weren't that light before that's when I
was like I felt a little shame
eventually I learned to you know it took
me a while it took me awhile to actually
love the skin that I am
[Music]